most of us don't think much about the
oceans tides tide goes in tide goes out
it's just some water moving because the
moon and the Sun are pulling on it but
those words just some water hide an
incredible amount of matter and pulling
on it
hides an unimaginable amount of force
and nowhere is that more obvious than
right here i'm just north of the Arctic
Circle in Norway half an hour's drive
through a talent called border the land
here is mostly what Douglas Adams called
lovely crinkly edges and this particular
lovely crinkly edge howls the sellstrom
and Maelstrom the most powerful tidal
current on the planet and the reason so
powerful that way is the sea that way is
a fjord a tidal Inlet twice a day here
the sea rises and falls by about two
meters so the water level in the fjord
tries to equalize the catch is that
pretty much all the water it needs to do
that four hundred million cubic meters
give or take has to go through this
channel there are other routes that it
could take but the land masses make
those slow and shallow they're winding
country roads whereas this is like a 12
Lane freeway it's well it's a perfect
storm there's a huge mass of water on
both sides providing pressure and the
channel starts wide and steadily narrows
to the center both ways it's the right
width and the right shape to create this
maelstrom of whirlpools and currents and
vortices what surprised me the most
coming here and standing next to it is
how much it changes moment to moment
second to second every little twist in
the tide and the water creates a new
vortex and a new boil I had to get close
enough to stick my camera in on long
pole and honestly it terrified me tour
groups can take an inflatable boat out
into the channel and you'll see
occasional fishing vessels taking
advantage of all the marine life that
gets shunted through here but unlike the
whirlpools of myth and legend this
Maelstrom isn't gonna pull a modern
buoyant powered boat down to the doubts
although a swimmer on their own would be
in a lot of trouble and a large ship
might lose control and be dashed against
the rocks but all this force all this
water this is just a fraction of what's
being pulled around out on the ocean
it's just here it
visible it's on a human scale it's
threatening so here we pay attention to
it
[Music]